you're eight to move UT like right now
yeah we're gonna take a look into my
phone see what's poppin my lock screen
is some boring default Apple tink ya
offensive nothing special I'm at one
vimeo.com and this is a private link
someone new music video it's most of
most of the time it would be none it
would be mandals mandals media yeah it's
it hot too hot for me but then I put the
sauce on it medium sauce and that just
blows me ed off and makes me go red and
that so I can't I don't I don't get the
sauce for them when I'm around females
[Music]
baby for all all the way to the bottom
this is interesting I don't even know
myself got bad bad
touchdown in London came from money with
a pack it's only right that I go and
make a bangle with Salah still move mad
squeeze gaming in the cup
roll back to the gaff with somebody's in
the back and I don't know what yeah
that's duck that was the 10th of
December
she calls it an 18-day after me it's a
birthday so I must've got a new phone
because I definitely went my first-ever
bar but yeah so yet 7th of December
we've got some black I was obviously in
studio so back yeah my most recent no
it's like four words or something and it
just says yeah well I got red I got
white I'll let you I'll let you take
that and I know what is I think if you
listen kept you know what it is but yeah
yeah well I got read about white YouTube
to be honest which is a food which is a
funny one everyone lot something weird
when I say that but yeah YouTube to be
quite honest with that on my life right
now I've just got a notification off
YouTube by the way right right now just
letting you know them the most recent
song I've played is shoreline mafia
pressure
we've got them my some American Jesus
from LA he got some bangers but yeah
that was the most recent one nah I don't
you know I've got a playlist on Spotify
kind of kind of bring that into play
yeah I got players on Spotify and it is
just my songs you know what I'll be
honest with you yet the most acting most
actually one and I was listening to bear
bear the audios or not because nothing
about videos for all of them and so on
YouTube recently the most Awkward
however I think the album of listen to
be most overall is get rich or die tryin
50
[Applause]
[Music]